bonjour thierry amouroux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
on a vu cette déclaration d'olivier
ferrand qui parle du variant delta qui
saturaient les réanimations et le
variant au micro nu qui serait qu'il
statuerait délai ni conventionnelle
qu'en est il actuellement à l'hôpital
et c'est vrai qu'il ya une augmentation
de la pression sur sur l'hôpital avec
eux toujours plus d'entrées en
utilisation ou les plus d'entrées en
réanimation mais ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre aussi c'est que par rapport à
la première vague nous avons moins de
lignes et moi de personnel parce
qu'entre temps le gouvernement a
continué ses plans d'économies sur les
hôpitaux en fermant un délit à 5710 qui
ont été fermées en 2020 sur les hôpitaux
selon les propres statistiques du
ministère et puis il ya eu une vague de
départs de soignants qui sont épuisés au
bout de deux années de lutte les deux
suractivité d'une part leur dépit que
kovy mais entre deux vagues au vide est
bien là une suractivité pour prendre en
soit le plus de passion non qu'ovide
mêlée qui ont été déprogrammés lors des
pics au vide et dont tous ces patients
chroniques et bien
en fait il ya un retard et on essaye de
rattraper au mieux et donc il ya eu une
incompréhension d'aidé soignante de voir
le gouvernement
continuait réduire les moyens
contrairement au discours du quoi qu'il
en coûte et puis ben là concrètement
lorsqu'on voit que il ya une montée en
charge etc au lieu d'essayer de bloquer
cette montée en charge on reporte en la
rentrée scolaire est bon
on ouvre l'école et ce sans installer de
purificateurs d'air dans chaque classe
dont chacune de restauration des
demandes que l'on formule depuis
septembre 2020 au les mesures en fait on
sent que le gouvernement s'adapte au fur
et à mesure et fait tout finalement
pourra maintenir une vie normale on a
entendu des des professeurs réclamer des
masques ffp2 on dit que c'est réservé
aux soignants vous en pensez quoi
et que très peu de réunions liées aux
arrêts cédant les rênes inacio etc il
faut bien comprendre que eux
contrairement à d'autres pays dieu se
sont
imposés les fesses p2 pour tout public
que dans les transports parce que la
contamination se fait essentiellement
dans les menus klaus
l'imposé le masque à l'extérieur on
dehors des dunes oury passante ça n'a
pas grand intérêt ce qu'il faut c'est
lutter contre la contamination dans les
lieux clos et pour ça il faut mettre des
respirateurs dans les classes dans les
lieux de restauration
des établissements scolaires des
entreprises est également dans les
restaurants parce que c'est ça qui va
bloquer la transmission il faut que les
soignants puisse avoir des deux mais il
se serait qu'ils ont également cours
pour les enseignants tous ceux qui
restent longtemps dans un espace clos
avec eux d'autres personnes vous parlez
des des moyens de l'hôpital vous
comprenez que le gouvernement n'ait pas
augmenté les capacités problèmes de
recrutement peut-être aussi pour pour ne
pas pouvoir le faire
alors en fait il ya beaucoup plus de
départs que de que de recrutement par
exemple sur sur la php vous avez eu 3200
départ de l'infirmier depuis euh juin et
vous avez vu simplement 1845
heureusement ce qui fait un gros trou
mais ça c'est parce que les soignants
ils ont été dégoûtés par le gouvernement
qui est incapable de prendre les mesures
adaptées qui ont été broyés par le
système parce qu'on fait on est
considérés comme des pions déplacés on
était placé régulièrement d'un service
aloses vous êtes infirmier en
cardiologie monde et prendre deux postes
et puis ce but il manque quelqu'un dans
un autre service on vous des places dans
service et vous vous retrouvez en
insécurité professionnelle parce que
vous ne connaissez pas forcément les
pathologies de ses services vous ne
connaissez pas du tout les protocoles de
ce service vous ne savez on se trouve le
matériel dans ce service donc vous
faites ça plusieurs fois des soignants
ils ont envie de continuer et des
soignants qui continue à travailler
alors qu'eux mêmes sont positifs
alors ça c'est quelque chose qui nous
choque profondément parce que vous avez
le ministère qui trouve logique de
demander à des soignants qui ont une bcr
positif donc du virus dans le nez de
venir travailler s'ils sont
asymptomatiques ou s'ils sont ils ont
simplement quelques symptômes légers et
donc on se retrouve à travailler avec
des virus dans menée auprès de personnes
hospitalisées dont forcément fragile qui
risquent de développer la forme grave de
la maladie parce que tous ceux qui sont
hospitalisés n'ont pas le coc vide et
donc on risque de devenir des agents de
contamination et on a le sentiment que
le gouvernement échoue aux apprentis
sorciers avec des mesures pareilles pour
un virus aussi eu
transmissibles qu'au micro ni dernière
question ce variant ce variant omicron
dont vous parlez n'amène pas forcément à
une surpopulation dans les réanimations
est ce que vous nous le confirmer ça
aujourd'hui est ce que vous le constatez
oui en réanimation si essentielle ment
des gens qui ne sont pas vaccinés dont
corps heureusement la vaccination le
protège des des formes graves et eux
c'est que on est plus armé que lors de
la première vague quel que soit le le
pig omicron beaucoup plus contagieux
mais il semble présenter des formes
moins grave est ménée en les gens sont
hospitalisés pour mikron dans
des lits conventionnés os etc c'est
conventionnelle pardon c'est le cas
aujourd'hui comment sont ils traités et
pour quels symptômes
il y
à différentes formes il faut bien
comprendre que vous avez des malades
chroniques
qui sont
vaccinées mais qui
pour qui au mil de virus el loco vie
peut avoir des formes qui nécessitent
une hospitalisation
en conventionnel et pas forcément en
réanimation en lien avec leur pathologie
merci beaucoup thierry amouroux de nous
avoir apporté toutes ces précisions je
rappelle que vous êtes porte-parole du
syndicat infirmier snp merci